yeah I mean I mean it's it's kind of
like the the more the more that you know
exciting new tech comes up the
population is going to decline so no one
is going to [__] is what I'm learning
Japan Japanese
I think the highest birth rate in Asia
right now yeah yeah it does it does
career is like negative 500 that is
because they had League yeah yeah it is
that was like the one thing that Japan
was holding back I want my league it
won't get popular yeah we all have
babies there are more internet cafes
than children
Japan's like there is nothing worse than
gacha games and careers like that League
of Legends
Legends really is the the population
control
that is the dystopian population control
[__] League of Legends gacha games
and YouTubers that's it China was like
one child policy Korea was like legalism
0.5 or something holy [__] that's really
bad Jesus Korea's really really bad
right now Asia
Asians maybe it's the agency yeah
no y'all need to go outside and fall
damn no because like yeah I personally
for me with video games the more that
you know the more that I've grown up the
more I've just appreciated stylized like
the whole like stylized graphics and
style like cell shaded stuff I [__]
loves and I don't know if this is a this
is definitely a me preference thing
right uh because I've always like I was
fine like the Call of Duty phase like
the real kind of like the real more more
realistic looking shooters or everything
but I always loved the more let's say
car not cartoonish but the more yeah
like stylized expressive I feel like
that's more expressive you know like
Wind Waker Jet Set Radio type of games
right yeah I mean it's one of my
favorite games of all time and I've
already upset this but like I think
metal slog is just one of those games
that is aged so well yeah and it looks
it is a work of art today they went the
the work they put into making those
Sprites I mean oh my God everything
about that game is so good it is it is
one it is some of the most beautiful
explosion Sprites I've ever seen the age
so well it's so nice so well they went
above and beyond but I feel that's why
especially in like the Indie like game
scene right like those kinds of like
16-bit 32-bit games are still so popular
yeah a lot of people still look at them
being like you know what I love how
realistic games are becoming and you
know to the point where it's almost
indistinguishable but there's something
charming and special about this like
retro look you know whatever whatever it
might be I saw a meme it was like indie
game devs trying to decide what they
wanted their game to be and it was that
you know that guy about to press the
button yeah and it was like uh roguelike
uh metroidvania
platformer
[__] yeah I guess yeah but I guess it
makes sense because obviously you can't
make giant open worlds as an indie Dev
it's kind of tough well maybe you can
but it's obviously a lot harder and
making those other types of games yeah
yeah baseball sense
um yeah I hope they never stop doing
that because I do like that I do it's
now like every major Triple A Studio has
an apology letter on like speed dial it
just seems like every time there's a new
big release uh even though I'm not a
gamer I I for some reason I don't I know
when a game's release when I see the
apology letter because I didn't know
like Star Wars um uh I didn't know the
new Star Wars game was out until I saw
the apology letter and I was like oh
it's out okay I thought you wanted to
play that for a while
where you bought it after the apology
letter I I mean it's wrong with you I I
saw the reviews and I was just there and
they're all like oh there's a frame rate
drop issues and stuff like that and I'm
like I don't care about that God
literally did that I'm not gonna read
this but I'm happy for you oh sorry for
your loss you're a monster anyway I'm
like people complaining that Zelda
doesn't run at like 60 frames a second
or something and I'm like what is this
what happened oh it came out honestly
yeah it's like it's like okay I'll take
it yeah I mean like the only the only
time I don't believe if it is like a
cyberpunk kind of situation and that's
the thing right
um
obviously it's bad that cyberpunk
released in the you know in the
condition that it did with as many bugs
but now that I've played it recently
um now that I've actually waited a year
it's genuinely a [__] great game like
it is a great game yeah I mean
I mean do you think that they should get
as much time as needed and Gamers Gamers
should give them the benefit of the
doubts if they get if like if they end
up actually fixing the bugs with the
games or they're releasing a they just
announced um yeah they just announced a
DLC
oh yeah yeah like see because like this
is an interesting point in contexture
because it's like I the have you seen
the latest naked Jakey video yeah I he
made this comparison that I never really
thought about that actually made a lot
of sense of the whole like thing of you
know game comes out that's clearly
unfinished people complain but then when
the game developers fix all the glitches
and bugs and everything with the DLC
then people are like well done well done
for fixing your game and he made this
really cool comparison it's like that's
like if you went to a Taco Bell and you
paid for a full price taco and what you
received at the door was just the taco
shell and some lettuce right but then a
couple weeks later guy comes back and
gives you the rest of the taco and your
reaction is still Applause him he's like
that's exactly the same way that people
are looking at game developers and it's
like it's weird that that's the only way
we kind of view at that point and when
he said that I was like you know what
you kind of make a point why do we react
that way okay okay okay so so I got a
big big opinion all right okay yeah yeah
I did see that video as well yeah and
you know I understood where he was
coming from especially with that analogy
um because yeah I think part of the
reason uh so I'm gonna answer that
question part of the reason I think
people are happy when people fix the
game is because so many game developers
don't go back there's so many EAS out
there that release and unfinished
products and then just leave it like
that and then just never fix it so when
you have those one or two developers
like no man's sky like cyberpunk that
actually come back and actually commit
even though they've already made their
money to fixing the issues uh I do think
that deserves some kind of Praise like
some kind they deserve some kind of
Praise
um my like I guess
I guess my kind of like
to play like that was Advocate to that
kind of argument which is you know why
they're releasing an unfinished product
where which is like cyberpunk
was never ever going to be released in
time at the quality of standards that
people expected yeah and people the
expectations were too high the
expectations were way too high so the
argument is would you wait a year if
because this is what the example I
needed more than a year I mean I mean I
I waited a year and I played it at a you
know when I experienced cyberpunk it was
I've experienced like almost zero bugs
like nothing game breaking nothing it
didn't crash once there was no like game
breaking or immersion breaking glitches
I had I had some bad bugs yeah I was
just dropped through the floor and die
it was like bad yeah damn yeah so I
never experienced like any of that and
that was me waiting like a year to play
cyberpunk because I really wanted to
play cyberpunk and so monk mode I was
like I'll be patient but unfortunately
from what I can see people just aren't
patient you know yeah I I I yeah I
definitely agree people are not because
people always want to play the latest
and best game yeah and unfortunately a
lot of those games do not live up to the
hype yeah and I I was I was talking
about this on stream the other day I was
like I've enjoyed gaming so much more
when I stopped following what games were
being released and I just played a bunch
of games that I thought were interesting
yeah and if the game comes out and it's
amazing people will let you know yeah
yeah like I don't I don't feel any
pressure to play that game immediately
like I I know breath of the Wild's good
the new one I just haven't played it uh
I uh sorry to the kingdom I I know it's
good I don't care about playing it I'll
play it in my own time and I've just
found that I've enjoyed gaming way more
when I've taken that approach yeah uh
it's been more fulfilling because I can
also be like I never expected anything
from any of these games and when they're
good I'm always pleasantly surprised
yeah yeah for sure um so yeah I also I
also said something that I was
controversial and people told me it was
controversial well I hate DLC full stop
I just wish game companies didn't make
DLC
like all kinds of DLC or I am
by the time what's your gaming
philosophy tell me tell me your gaming
because okay because Alden ring is
coming out with a DLC that is crazy big
and it's awesome in Swag yeah
um and I'm sure it's [__] amazing
yeah but I am already done with Alden
ring in my mind yeah right which is a me
this is totally amazing right again yeah
if you want to go back into that world
fantastic
um I wish that they would just instead
of making more for a game that is
already kind of done just to use that
time to make like a second one or
something or make a new ringtone I just
like I know this is a [__] take
um but for me it's like I just don't
want to get reinvest in a DLC
pay like 20 30 bucks for something
when I already feel like I'm kind of out
of it like I'd rather just start
something new no I I actually agree with
that like if the DLC comes out not long
after the like original games came out
like you're still playing the game and
you're still invest in it and a DLC
comes out then I'll be like sweet but if
I if it's like a year or two in between
yeah or like you know even longer
sometimes and I'm just like well yeah
I've kind of already checked out yeah
I'm like two games in to something else
like do I really want to jump I I it's
it's probably worth going back in like
that's one of the rare occasions where I
feel like it's worth it but especially
when some of these games split it up
into like four or five DLCs like there's
also a lot of DLCs where I just look at
it I'm like [__] it might look fine but
I just can't be bothered at all it looks
like [__] I want egregious example I
think um Pokemon sword and shield yeah
and that came out with [__] and they're
like no no but the DLC makes is such a
game changer what would have been a game
changer if the game was [__] good
yeah and it was compelling and I mean
no no uh Shield
um oh yeah the two expansions yeah well
we say we're bragging about how amazing
they were foreign
well in my case let's like I already had
beaten the game 100 so I'm like I'm I'm
done with this game like I don't want to
go back I felt I felt burnt I was like
you think I'm a [__] idiot do you
think I'm gonna come crawling back give
you money for the chance that it'll be
good [__] off bro you already took sixty
dollars from me and it sucked that's
like if like an anime was really dog
[__] and they're like no no what's the
OVA yeah it's fine it's fine Joey though
I I have three words to completely throw
a spanner in your argument okay Persona
5 Royal
see
when I heard that I would not count that
as a DLC 100 percent of five real why
would you not count it as a DS DLC DLC
because they for one the base game they
come they changed so many elements of
the story that it offered a completely
new feel to the story and it actually is
I feel you know what it was I heard the
sound deals for me Persona 5 and I might
just be the only one thing is Persona 5
Royal to me is not a DLC it's like an HD
expansion
uh what's what the [__] is the
difference the expansion is a DLC yeah
no no expansion in the sense of like it
well no because DLC is usually just like
in the case of like sword and shield
right it's like they tack it off to
something that is pretty because
reimagining yeah it's like a reimagining
basically wait so it's like a more
fleshed out version of something that is
completely different from the Baseline
the question to somebody who doesn't
know either yeah if I was to jump into
the Persona game yeah which one is the
Persona experience
that's why I grew up so it makes percent
of five kind of yeah yeah it does like
that's what I [__] up they bring out a
game that's like oh yeah by the way the
old one [__] useless now yeah it's
it's kind of like
um I mean that's why I brought up
Persona 5 Royal is the argument because
I know you [__] love it
um but I'm like Persona 5 Royal has made
Persona 5 the base game just totally did
it piss you off though you paid money
for Persona five and then they like a
year later they were like oh by the way
Persona 5 but better yeah you know what
Atlas take my money
there are two Gamers inside of Joey yeah
one he's the only one loves Persona 5
Royal I hate DLCs if they're not done by
Atlas
we've been doing that since 2010. no
they did it with Persona 4 as well
though yeah yeah they did it within
three four and three and three yeah yeah
I mean you know what every single time
the the reimagined expansion version of
it has always been better yeah but that
doesn't mean that that doesn't that that
for me though that doesn't take away
from the experience of playing the
original game either because I still
have great memories of playing the
original Persona 5 when it came out yeah
right but now there's just like an added
experience on top of it yeah I mean I I
actually can agree with you with DLC the
way I really think about it right with
something like Persona 5 uh or like
percent five Royale or a lot of these
DLCs is the way I think about it it's
kind of just like
um the Lord of the Rings director's cup
you know do you want the do you want the
three hour director's car and most of
the time I I say no right the most for
most games I don't really care about DLC
I think the only DLC I've actually
bought and enjoyed is the mass effect
DLC and that's my favorite game of all
time you know
um so
you know there is there can be good
content with DLC but most of the time
DLC appeals to me if I haven't played
the game yet you know if I because yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because I try playing something like the
like Horizon zero Dawn DLCs and the
problem is once you've checked out of
the game once you've completed it and
it's been like [__] months and months
DLC yeah DLC one you don't care two
you've got to love it three it's a lot
of time it builds on the base game to be
like post endgame content and by that
point I've already forgotten all the
[__] mechanics you know and the
muscle memory is gone so I'm just
fighting monsters that are like I'm a
beginner uh fighting monsters are like
10 levels above what I remember them
being yeah so I'm like [__] I I've got
to relearn this game just to play the
DLC you know
um and unless the game's simple enough
I'm probably not going to play it and I
agree I would prefer just to get another
base game rather than just I want to
invest myself in like a 30 to 40 hour
a period of like gameplay rather than
just a 10 hour attack on if I hadn't
played the game that's great I get 10
more hours of this extra game that I'm
already invested in yeah um definitely
Case by case for sure yeah I mean I
think the reason it might work for
Royale or something like that is because
it's just a completely finished game you
know yes it's a it's a completely
finished story there is no I mean I say
this but they they did make more pursue
in five just not I don't know what they
did persona for other [__] uh hack
and slash Persona oh [__] I just
realized I made my own argument
irrelevant because that is [__]
[Applause]
why the [__] are they so against putting
their things on PC what are they Atlas
yeah it is on PC it is
yes it is on PC yeah absolutely recently
yes recently why why recently especially
Microsoft because because game is like
you complained loud
no I I wanted it like two years ago yeah
three years ago yeah but you have to
remember as well that like it took 10
years for them to make Persona 5 after
Persona 4. so they are very slow moving
in that sense but in that case you know
what Atlas has very few misses in my
opinion so it's it's worth the wait okay
yeah I'm letting them cook we have I
know Persona 6 has gonna come out in
like 2050 but you know what I'm I'm
gonna let them cook yeah it's gonna be a
good yes he's here's the thing like
there is not just with games there is
enough media out there to satisfy your
boredom if you don't have something to
play there is enough of a [__]
backlog uh if a game releases if
something like cyberpunk does release in
a buggy form yes of course there is some
fault with the game developers for
releasing that early but a lot of folk
also comes with the company as well for
having uh for setting unrealistic
release schedules well the company is I
mean I I as much as uh uh I'm I'm not
sympathetic towards companies at all
yeah uh but obviously they're just like
all right we have this much money you
gotta this is how long it'll last you've
got to get something out by then and
obviously it's not ready it's like well
we either cut the game or we give more
money or we push it out right now yeah
and uh I mean I think it's just a the
industry is just not in a good spot
right now people are not being paid
enough yep anyway so yeah but the thing
is a lot of these game companies make
like record profits which is like okay
okay so what's the excuse so where's it
going
stop paying Activision stop giving your
CEO a 20 million dollar bonus and make a
God [__] good game yeah I mean gamers
are one of the community that I see
complained the most yet somehow they
[__] the most they they keep giving them
money yeah yeah I when I I'm so firmly
against pre-ordering uh I'm a people
pre-ordered [__] I'm like what's wrong
with you you're the reason why we can't
have nice things because they know they
can release this like [__] and you'll
buy it yeah
all right what do you guys think of
Early Access then I hate this yeah I
hate it I know that nope they advertised
it and it's like no they released it
they put it out there people are gonna
play it and they're gonna they're gonna
think that's the game yeah I don't know
yeah yeah I mean to me Early Access it's
like crowdfunding yeah essentially the
way I see it like it's more of a hey
invest in this idea if you do I promise
I'll fix it but there's no there's no
problem
to me like Early Access is cyberpunk's
release with better PR you know I've
never really understood Early Access to
me as I understand it like conceptually
on paper but in practice I'm like well I
think it makes sense like you said
conceptually but I think it it just has
been abused yeah a lot of people you
know especially in like horror games
they'll just make a half-baked horror
game breaking a bunch of money getting
that Pat video and then they're like all
right
I don't like it anymore
it's got a good old map pack keeping
Early Access horror games alive
geez like it's like you look at
something like Poppy's play time and
like you're in I was in like Fuji q and
they were selling uh
yeah they were selling [__] poppy
playtime plushies in fujiku I'm like
what the [__] is this game that big yeah
what the hell